okay let's hear from a few more people
people in the audience people like you
you can talk to me through the david
pakman show discord which you can find
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to adam
from philadelphia adam you're on the air
uh hey i just wanted to say thanks but
um can you hear me a lot in queer though
yes i can um with uh
republican parents like mine who are
completely
against the vaccine and covert and all
and versus someone who hang on
they are not letting me take it at all
and i'm only 17
and and my mom's reasons are not
political i know that but my dads are
they are fox viewers every now and then
they
they are complete yeah they're complete
republicans and all they don't
trust the science and all that they're
though but
what is your message to those teenagers
out there who
are not allowed to get the vaccine so to
be clear you're saying you're not
your parents won't allow you to get the
vaccine is that right
that is correct okay the first thing is
in some states you don't need your
parents to allow you to get it when
you're 17. have you first explored what
the the law is in your state
no i have not okay so the first thing to
know is in many states when you're 17
you can just go and get the vaccine they
don't you don't need your parents to do
anything so if you were to decide that
that's something you want to do if it's
legal
you could investigate whether that's a
possibility does that make sense
yeah okay second part is how far from
being 18 are you
six months okay five months so at the
most in five months you can get the
vaccine right i mean no matter what even
if you can't get it today because of the
the
you need parental permission in five
months you can get it so what i would
say is
wear a mask and be careful until that
time
i mean you know your parents better than
i do it it sounds like it's a lost cause
trying to convince them right like
you're not gonna be able to convince
them
yeah my mom um she she's actually more
like afraid of it i should say like
i think that's what you need to like we
need to understand is like
why sometimes they're not gonna be
taking it is because of
like my mom always tells it's the it's
just the style of it
and my dad says oh but you know j j
that's
that's not really what moderna and
pfizers are doing at all but
my mom's always saying though but
there's all these reports about jane jay
coming down about
you know these these heart problems and
stuff that's all they talk about
yeah i mean you know listen again the
question is does it make sense to argue
with your parents and say the risk of
covet is much greater than the risk
of the heart thing um but i just don't
know because you might be able to go get
vaccinated now depending on the law in
your state or in five months you can i
just don't know if it's worth fighting
with them i just i don't know
yeah i never tried doing that because
again i know what they really do believe
in
if i if i really try to tell them the
truth and all they they are
really they are really third against you
they let me ask you this adam
is your mom less against it than your
dad
um i don't think so i think she's not
really
against i think she's again more
skeptical of it she's
a skeptic but what i'm saying is if
there was one parent who would be more
okay with you getting the vaccine would
it be your mom or your dad
probably my dad yeah okay so maybe when
your mom's not around you go to your dad
and you say dad listen
i need to be protected i need to go and
get the vaccine will you come with me so
that i can get it and just see what he
says
okay i mean i don't know and again you
might be you this might be moot because
17 year olds in your state might be able
to just go get vaccinated you might not
need your parents permission
yeah that i have to look into it then
check it out all right adam let us know
how it turns out okay
okay all right thank you yeah that's
that's tough i mean we get a lot of
calls like that
it's uh it's it's pretty wacky
pretty wacky why don't we go next
to john from philly john you're on the
air
hey good afternoon how are you dave hey
this is john from the dr right
living in philly yes how are you i
remember you i remember you
how are you i'm doing well very well
very well
so my question is um
what is the deal with the um
with this democratic uh
which i call it the
um without this project the
uh infrastructure beer that they trying
to push
are you talking about chuck schumer i'm
not sure who you mean
you know yeah in the senate they they
try to push
the infrastructure beer and
they never success and anything i i
guarantee to you
yeah that if the republicans were in
control
of the house the senate and the white
house
they would push the very immediately oh
of course oh my goodness
john if republicans were in the
situation democrats are in right now
uh everything would be done they'd have
passed tax reform
they would just what is the deal with
the democrats
hoarding of the bill i don't understand
that well
holding up i mean part of the problem
john is no the democrats aren't even on
the same page about what they want to
pass
you have people like joe manchin and
kirsten cinema who don't want the same
things that bernie sanders wants
and because they have of the slimmest
possible majority
nothing gets done that's what's going on
yeah but i i'm going back again to the
same thing
yeah like you okay republican may block
the beer or something but
you know they control the white house
you know yeah
you know maybe binding can push it we
are
you know we all support anybody you know
i'm saying they aren't controlling my
house
i agree and listen john if joe biden
doesn't
get something major done with democrats
in what's left of this calendar year
i think democrats get crushed in next
year's midterm elections
i i guarantee that that is going to
happen yeah i guarantee
because they don't you know they're
waiting for nothing yep
there's no what are they doing it makes
i i completely agree with you john
it doesn't make no sense yeah waiting
for nothing
you're you're absolutely right well
let's see let's see if they get anything
done
all right davey both uh nice talking to
you you have a wonderful day sir you too
there's john from philly
uh great to hear from him as always